the number one thing a man can do to
help his
dating life is to be the leader with the
women
take charge be the be the man you have
to as a man if you want a relationship
and you want to have a girlfriend and
all that stuff you have to learn how to
be a leader the man is the head of the
household it's been like that since the
dawn of civilization
and like i said recently we've stayed
we've strayed away from that
and everybody's [ __ ] miserable who's
falling who's fallen away from that
women don't want to be in charge they
like you ever see a chick who's in
charge of a relationship she's miserable
she's a [ __ ] she's aggressive she's
like she's like rolling her eyes a
husband or boyfriend and eventually that
kind of relationship
ends women lose respect for a man like
that but there's important things that
women
do well and should be in charge of like
there's certain areas that women's
like they bring like my mom says a
woman's touch to things is always going
to be different than a man
himself but you don't want to be the
majority holder in charge
no i mean i mean i wouldn't say like
okay i don't want to be working until
all these hours and years of my life but
maybe i'm better in charge of
raising the kids you know maybe i'm
better in charge of um you know adding
some
value to my husband or you know there's
there's areas that women they bring
something to a man i didn't say women
didn't bring value i just said that men
should be the leaders of the
relationship right that's what that's
the point right but then women but women
also lead in certain areas better no
there can't be two leaders no no but
they lead in bet they lead in areas
better than men in some areas and
something for example um i've seen i
feel like women are able to maybe
connect with the kids a little bit
better than a man
yeah fair you feel like that yeah but i
mean think about it you guys are
basically saying the same thing because
the leader of the household what what
does that mean you're you're you're
paying the bills follow the shots all
final decisions come to the ceo and he
vetoes it if need be but what natalia is
saying is like listen i've got a role
too it's not maybe the le it's that role
it's i'm gonna i'm gonna take care of
the house yeah i'm gonna take care of
the kids yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna carve
my niche that i'm gonna kind of
bring myself
she's misusing the word leader okay you
you could the man is the leader she is
she is you'll learn uh but the thing is
the man has to be the head of the
household all final decisions run
through him yeah okay and then the woman
she can be in charge of things i agree
that there are certain things a woman
does is that a leader though nothing in
charge of things why no no no why
because
like it doesn't work like that you can't
like
every every religious text all this
stuff has been going back since the dawn
of civilization like you cannot have two
leaders like a house divider upon the
self stance a a a company doesn't have
two ceos no they do not okay
so just because there's a ceo and this
is cfo he's better than you know the ceo
when it comes to running money so you
can make him do that you're delegating
responsibility but that doesn't diminish
her role
and i think modern women nowadays they
they have like this insecurity this
complex like what do you mean like i'm
not number one like i need to have like
that equal equality with the man but it
there's not equality the equality is no
they're and i agree it's not real
there's no it's it's
something that they got indoctrinated in
the education system and we have to
believe it
for because if we do don't believe that
men or women are equal we're horrible
because you're delegating a role to
your child or you're one of your kids
that you're asking them to lead whoever
is behind them they're not the head
leader but you're asking them to to
execute leadership roles and i think
that's important for everybody man women
and female maybe there's certain areas
like okay this leader obviously has to
be led by someone else yes for sure but
if you're delegating responsibilities
you're essentially asking them hey i
want you to take lead in this area and
once that's take lead like i want you to
come back to me and then we can game
plan together and i'm gonna
take the family to xyz but i think if
you're delegating a role
somewhere in your i like when you have
kids and stuff like you delegate roads
to your kids like hey listen i want you
to spend a little time with your brother
because you know he's struggling in this
area and you know you're essentially
no but i've i grew up with siblings
where it's like my mother may ask me hey
now like i want you to talk to your
sister a little bit you know not because
i'm gonna get them to sex but they may
go to them now because they're not
getting that some people need like the
instructions to go to the leader from
someone else like if i'm like hey
brianna you know or my sister like hey
listen like you know you're struggling
this area x y and z she's probably going
to be like offended by that me saying
but now she's going to go to my parents
who are the actual leaders
and seek the advice correctly so it's
like when you are delegating
like instructions in the household it's
still essentially assigning leadership
natalia you i know your parents well we
were just with them okay shout out to
marvin and dee great people
um would you say that marvin's the
leader of the household yeah i would say
he's the leader but i would say my mom
essentially is like our commander like
hey mom like this is this and then
she'll go to my dad so i do look at her
as a leader
you know they say that the man is the
head but the woman is the neck yeah
yeah because your mom doesn't strike me
as like yes sir what is that like she's
a boss yes but she's also feminine the
boss is such a very graceful way and she
respects her husband and my dad does
lead her but he is the leader like yeah
speaking on stage in front of twenty
thousand thousand okay but mothers they
do hold a very important role
in a way i actually like what you're
saying is like the dad's the ceo that
doesn't mean that the mom can't be the
cfo or the cmo
whatever that's what i'm saying it does
it's not a leader follower
it's it kind of is is it yeah because
that's the bottom line like he has the
final say
that's what makes him a leader
the final saying what though all
decisions you know what i mean like he
has the ultimate power who's the person
they discuss it with but so there's no
compromise in a relationship i didn't
say there is compromise there's no
compromise he will if if a man loves
this woman he'll hear her out yeah but
at the end of the day he has the final
sense that's that's how it is
that's how it works in your house and
that's the definition of a leader so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire sauce cast click right here
[Music]